you can be pretty savvy yeah it's a
quality that I that's what you think
I've kind of always seen that person you
know the lights of the party maybe you
don't really know them but you know who
they are and I always wanted to be that
but I just don't know how I'm generally
not wanting to make eye contact with
strangers I assume people don't want me
to say hi to them unless they say hi to
me first and you know maybe it's my own
insecurity or lack of confidence but I
figure we're making videos we're trying
things let's see if it's possible to
make yourself more likeable in one week
to figure out what I had to change I
first asked my coworkers
one of the things that I like about
people is like when people make eye
contact with me getting on their level
did you guys might be helpful this is a
small area I think a likable person is
friendly is they'll ask you about your
day and they'll invest like a certain
amount of time into other people yeah I
always say hi to people very wait for
people to say hi to me I know take
initiative because I'm afraid that they
do not want me to talk to them when
people ask questions about others it
makes other people feel good because
they feel like other people care about
them you know your address you have a
very unique style of you do you think
stuff like that it kind of helps with
people like likability too when
somebody's a little bit more put
together I like will appreciate them a
little bit more I'm excited well good
luck my love could any of this be
validated by science would these
suggestions actually make me more
likeable I reached out to some experts
and psychologists to get an expert
opinion unfortunately none of those
people replied so we're off to a great
start I enlisted our research department
to see if there was anything scientific
I could do to enhance my likability a
study in 1996 revealed that bright
clothing is generally associated with
positive feelings and others research
has also shown that people love to
answer questions about themselves in
casual conversation according to
research published in 2013 humor can
make other people feel close to you and
is linked to feelings of liking several
studies have revealed that social
interactions can be perceived more
positively if the participants smile
more throughout the work week I would
follow these rules and on the final day
I would throw a party yes me hosting a
party I'm looking for my brightest to my
most colorful clothes to wear this week
and my options are limited just I don't
be able to wear on my beautiful this is
my first lightly colorful outfit Billy
is not that colorful but yeah ease into
it I don't know what I'm gonna do if
there's not anybody in the canteen to
talk to Karen how was your weekend hey
Freddy hey how's it going to watch Game
of Thrones are you hoarding all this
fruit is that your fruit good I went to
shows tiny what did you do yeah you were
there yeah yeah usually when I talk to
people it's like oh hey can you be in
this video okay can I ask you a question
for this video or something so I feel
like people are surprised that I'm
talking to them with no goal other than
to just talk how was your Sunday
my aunt always does like dinners on
Sundays because she loves Game of
Thrones - did you do anything else
exciting this weekend
alright see ya
I'm trying to be slightly more put
together than I normally am this week
but I realized that I just kind of look
like an old McDonald
[Music]
so this outfit it may not be the most
all one of these pins Oh crazy things I
blew it
I really I do not do great today and
that's on me you know some days you just
don't want to talk and that was today
but tomorrow's another day and it's
another opportunity to be loved by all
outfit oh sorry outfit day three
something I'll just try and tell a joke
to every person I meet today hey Katie
you wanna hear a joke
what did Arnold Schwarzenegger call his
an Italian restaurant hasta la vista
baby again was great they a lot of
people thought I was gonna like scare
them or do something bad
which isn't great but I think just the
more that I do it probably the more
normal it's gonna seem so the
unnaturalness of it like people could
tell that it was being forced I think
that's kind of maybe the only way that
it becomes natural is to kind of force
yourself to do it at first and then
maybe it'll you know be more natural as
you go it's very exhausting this is the
most colorful thing I own I can't wait
till I can dress like [ __ ] again I
decided to dye my hair before the party
to signify my transformation into a
social butterfly alright decorations are
sorted and the only thing left to do is
wait so hopefully people come people
cannot resist food you put out food you
put out drinks people come yeah go ahead
sit you know enjoy I get a beverage
[Music]
party's winding down kind of quicks I
did I see some people walking by and I
tried to lure them in and they kind of
ignored me so that was a low point but I
feel like it's going okay she seemed I
would say more interested in talking
about us I don't think she's ever asked
about that weekend yeah I talked to
Sarah she was super cool we played with
bubbles there was a certain part during
the party where I saw that the bubbles
had died down and I was like I wonder if
anyone's gonna get on that she refilled
it like that DUI she seemed particularly
like confident she was really nice she
introduced herself to me which was nice
we had met one time before so I got free
beer I got free cookies I got free cake
so I can definitely say she was great
house I don't interact with her very
much but on the times that I had she's
been very nice yeah same here
yeah before introducing yourself to
people she didn't know something I yeah
I haven't seen her do before she offered
us a seat she even gave up her seat for
us hearing what people thought about the
party made me realize that you know
putting in the effort can yield results
I really didn't realize before how I
came off just because it did not occur
to me truly to ever do these things even
though they seem like common sense I
definitely feel like more comfortable
talking to people and I'm excited to you
know get to know more people and connect
with them
[Music]